qué expresiones son equivalentes a x +
torio más x + 2 elige todas las opciones
correctas así que veamos si puedo
manipular esta expresión un poquito
antes de fijarme en estas opciones así
que para empezar digamos que está de
nuevo por aquí tengo x + 2
más
x +
y la primera cosa que me saltan
inclusive antes de ver estas opciones es
que aquí tenemos una equis y aquí
tenemos otra equis entonces podemos
sumar esta x del inicio con esta otra
equis y nos dará 2x así que déjame
atraparlo con este color
tengo una x al inicio esta de aquí y
después tengo esta otra x por acá y
entonces las puedo sumar y bueno para no
saltarme pasos déjame ponerlo de esta
manera esto es lo mismo que tener x +
x 22 así que lo voy a poner con negro +
2 james
más
y entonces estas dos equis de aquí las
puedo sumar y las puedo escribir de la
siguiente manera me quedaría 2x + 2
yemas 2
james más
y ahora veamos de mis opciones la
segunda es 2x + 4 y + 4 así que esa no
es la respuesta porque tenemos 2 x + 2 y
+ 2 por lo tanto puedo descartar esta
que tenemos aquí no es nuestra respuesta
correcta y observemos el primer inciso
se ve muy interesante porque tiene un
factor de 2 100 nuestra expresión
sacamos al 2 como factor que obtenemos
bien pues puedes ver que el 2 es un
factor de este que tenemos aquí también
del segundo término y también del tercer
término por lo tanto si lo sacamos como
factor que nos va a quedar vamos a sacar
este 2 como factor voy a sacar este 2
como factor y también vamos a sacarlos
de aquí
bueno pues voy a tener a 2
y primero multiplica a x así que lo voy
a poner con su respectivo color magenta
2 que multiplica a x + déjame ponerlo
con este color más que 2 que multiplica
allí más y si factor izamos el 2 de aquí
nos vamos a quedar solo con 1 por lo
tanto no voy a poner aquí 2 x x + 1 y
date cuenta que es exactamente lo mismo
que tenemos en nuestra primera opción
por lo tanto vamos a seleccionar la y
bueno si estamos eligiendo una opción
entonces en definitiva la respuesta no
es ninguna de las anteriores